hey guys ryan right here alcohol um
we're not gonna watch the trailer there
no now I'm here to make a little
announcement you know I've been uh
noticing some people on YouTube have
been copying the channel a little bit
copying the structure a little bit you
might even say they're a bunch of [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] I was looking at some
channels and I was like you know a lot
of people have been asking me to do this
as well and I figured why not join in on
the fun QA time people QA you guys put
down your questions and this
[ __ ] is gonna answer the best
once the best make them like real
questions you know not like hey how many
times have you bang Veronica not gonna
say that won't answer that but I am full
of a lot of energy I have a lot of
stamina whatever the average is a man
can perform I'm like wave of that let's
just say that okay okay it's okay baby
yeah yeah if you have a question I have
an answer for you put it down there and
the other thing is I'm going to seattle
this weekend for tough mudder the 10 to
12 mile obstacle course to help promote
the edge of tomorrow blu-ray release I
have been losing weight but of course a
few days before the event I decided to
have a whole box of little caesars to
myself didn't see that coming it was
like oh five bucks I'll just probably
have like two slices and then before you
know you're watching true blood and
you're like eating all them okay so [ __ ]
happens if I'm out in Seattle and you're
out in Seattle you just let me know cuz
I want to meet you that's right we're
gonna meet each other if you live in
Seattle that I know [ __ ] about Seattle I
would just like to have fun out there
anyway I don't really quite get what to
do in these little announcement videos
but what else can I announced i'm gonna
be posting mainly a night now to make it
fun for you guys anywhere from six to
midnight cuz im to lazy isn't for myself
a proper schedule about her
right now usually after 10pm somewhere
between 10 to midnight I've been testing
out times and that's the best time for
most people for most subscribers so yeah
anyway guys yeah those are the three
things QA going to Seattle if you live
in Seattle come pay me a visit and keep
a lookout just stop doing everything out
in the evening when you get home from
work and get off from school stop you
masturbate but once you get that email
notification remotes you know to go on
youtube.com slash the real rejects I
think we're done